bonjour patrick moreau joue merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous ce
matin sur rtl france est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire plus sur ce parti
qui a fait une percée aux élections
régionales un parti anti vax oui tout à
fait c'est un nouveau phénomène bon le
parti a fait 6 32% des voix à trois élus
c'est un parti qui
est difficile à classifier c'est à dire
que lorsqu'on regarde le passé politique
des dirigeants de ce parti michael braun
heure par exemple
ce sont des gens qui l'ont pas ou qui
n'ont pas eu d'activités politiques
connues ces dernières années et non pas
vu non plus de contacts avec l'extrême
droite l'extrême droite c'est à dire le
s&p et a depuis très longtemps tenté de
récupérer le mouvement de protestation
anti corps humain ce qui n'a pas ce qui
n'a pas vraiment réussi un grand nombre
de gens qui sont hostiles à la politique
mise en place par le gouvernement
on cherchait une
mécanisme d'expression et donc ils sont
en train de préparer ce qu'on appelle
une consultation populaire à une sorte
de référendum et puis en haute-autriche
ils ont décidé de fonder un parti de
manière tout à fait expérimental et ça a
très bien marché
alors on sait à peu près précisément
pourquoi les gens se sont décidés à
voter pour ce pour ce parti et
lorsque on a une social graphie très
précises des gens qui ont choisi ce
parti on s'aperçoit que fondamentalement
c'est une ligne défendant la liberté
d'expression ce qu'on appelle of freedom
of speech et deuxièmement c'est une
combi nations avec un une dimension
qu'on connaît aussi en france ce qu'on
appelle les antilles vax ce n'est pas un
parti fondamentalement politique c'est
uniquement centré sur la question de la
disparition ou non des droits
constitutionnels en autriche et pourquoi
finalement certains autrichiens assez
nombreux se sont tournés vers ce parti
c'est parce que les restrictions sont
trop durs en autriche aujourd'hui c'est
à dire qu'il ya eu le même problème
qu'en france c'est à dire des
difficultés du gouvernement autrichien a
explicité pourquoi un certain nombre de
mesures réduisez les libertés
individuelles
ça a été très belles fesses évidemment
maintenant il ya une correction ou via
c'est d'ailleurs avec le recul de
l'épidémie l'intensité je dirais
interventionniste de l'état assez réduit
mais fondamentalement tout ça ne
fonctionne pas très bien on le voit en
france aussi c'est le même phénomène
c'est à dire que les gens voudraient un
traitement équivalent entre l'hier
vacciner et les noms matinée le deuxième
problème de celui des écoles
effectivement la politique qui a été
suivie fait qu'un grand nombre d'écoles
sont fermées et que un certain nombre de
parents commencent à trouver que la
situation est intenable sur le long
terme
justement qu'en est il de la situation
sanitaire à présent en autriche est ce
qu'elle est satisfaisante
elle est aussi peu satisfaisante qu'elle
ne l'est quelle nulle et ailleurs en
allemagne ou en france il ya
effectivement une réduction du nombre de
cas mais il n'y a pas encore de contrôle
de l'épidémie et surtout l'épidémie
risque encore de durer un certain temps
donc fondamentalement je dirais 7
il faut voir aussi qu'à peu près 10 de
10 à 15% de la population ne veut pas se
laisser vacciner donc le gouvernement se
trouve confronté à un défi sa voix s'il
doit imposer des mesures coercitives
oui ou non et dans ce cadre et c'est la
problématique essentielle de ce nouveau
parti il ya ce qu'on appelle une volonté
de clarifier sur le plan constitutionnel
la validité des mesures de répression et
c'est en cours
il est très difficile de savoir comment
le tribunal constitutionnel va se
positionner sur la question des mesures
coercitives et des autres y ciel qui
sont un peu plus réfractaires à la
vaccination qu'en france cette cet
attachement à l'aller orthez s'est ancré
dans les mentalités autrichienne
excellente question je crois que dans la
génétique des partis allemands il ya une
une tendance naturelle à respecter
l'autorité
simplement je dirais de 10 à 15% de la
population
n'arrive pas à comprendre la logique des
mesures en place donc ça ça a très peu à
voir en fait avec cela c'est simplement
parce que lorsque vous êtes confrontés à
des mesures d'interdiction veillez à
vous les acceptez ou vous n'acceptez pas
et plus les mesures d'interdiction
de vienne intensive plus les réactions
si vous voulez de résistance est le
maître mot qui est utilisé par ce parti
se multiplient et surtout se durcissent
donc on va vers une fracture sociale en
autriche mais comme on peut l'observer
en france ou en allemagne a
effectivement maintenant une linéarité
de la population qui est entré en
résistance contre l'état merci beaucoup
patrick moreau d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce matin sur rtl france je le
rappelle vous êtes chercheur au cnrs au
laboratoire dynamique européenne de
l'université de strasbourg spécialiste
de l'autriche